Ukrainian forces have lost
a significant amount
of troops and heavy equipment
in their assault
on Russian lines in the east.
That is what a senior U.S.
official is telling CNN.
Two of them, actually.
This is coming
just days after Ukraine's deputy
defense minister said
an offensive is taking place
in several directions.
My next guest
is part of a bipartisan coalition
that just sent a letter
to President Biden, again urging the U.S.
to provide Ukraine with fourth generation
fighter jets.
That's a move that Russia says
would bring enormous risks.
We're joined now by Congressman
Jason Crow.
He is on the House Intelligence
and Foreign Affairs Committees.
He's also a former Army Ranger
who served three
combat tours in Iraq and Afghanistan.
And he is now the co-chair
of the bipartisan four country caucus.
A lot of stuff,
but I think all relevant to
what we're talking about here today,
this letter,
you're putting a lot of pressure
on the president.
The president has softened on F-16's
a little bit.
He has softened on these attack
arms, these longer range missile systems.
So what do you want out of this?
Just for him to move faster?
And what is the difference between him
going at the pace he's
going and going at the pace
you want him to?
Well, it's good to be with you.
And I want to be really clear
that I think the president
and this administration
have done a remarkable
job of building
a coalition of over 50 countries,
most of whom have actually contributed
to the Ukrainian war effort,
that is the world's
largest coalition
in support of a partner at war.
We have
we have moved a massive amount
of arms, ammunition and equipment
We have trained multiple brigades
of the Ukrainian military.
So this effort has been significant.
But in war,
no day is like the last one days change,
weeks change.
We have to evolve with the war effort.
And what this letter is saying,
this is a bipartisan effort
by the veteran's caucus in the House.
We're coming out and saying
that you have the overwhelming
bipartisan support
of the House of Representatives,
the change, the nature of our support
to move certain things faster,
but also provide some longer range
strike capability
in the form of aircraft
and long range rockets
to help the Ukrainians win this.
If they don't do that.
On the timeline
that you're searching for,
I mean, what's the risk
Well,
the risk is,
is that the Ukrainians
have a series of wins and battles,
but they could lose the longer term war.
The timelines here
are different, Brianna,
but Vladimir Putin is playing
a long game.
He's looking one year,
two years, three years out.
He thinks that the West
and Democratic nations
will lose interest,
that we can't
sustain the political support.
And he can just grind this out.
He's willing to send
100,000 200,000
Russians to their death
in hopes
that he can win this in the long term.
So what we have to do is help
the Ukrainians
win this in the short or mid-term.
Help them
destroy the Russian military
and their capacity to wage war.
Now, let's talk about the longer term
of supplying
something like F-16s to the Ukrainians.
They need logistical support.
They need maintenance on that. Right.
These are finely tuned machines.
How would Ukraine get that
if they get F-16s from the U.S.?
Well, that's
what our letter calls for, is
an expedited
all of government,
all of alliance effort
to train the pilots,
find the F-16s and transfer them
either directly from the United States
or a transfer from one of our allies,
as there's F-16s
throughout the NATO's alliance
in several countries,
might be able
to transfer
them much quicker than we could,
but also train the maintainers
These are sophisticated aircraft.
That's why they're so good
They require a tremendous amount of back
end support and sustainment.
So we're going to train the mechanics.
We're going to have to get
the fuel supplies going.
There's a lot of things
that have to happen now
so that six months, nine months from now,
these aircraft can be flying over
Ukrainian skies.
And that's what we're pushing
the administration to do.
The Russian foreign minister,
Sergey Lavrov, said F-16s
could accommodate nuclear weapons.
He's clearly sending a message here.
What is he really saying is you see it?
And does that dissuade you at all
from pushing for this?
Well, first of all, this administration
and President Biden
have been very careful
of making sure that we are
we are not escalating,
that we're not doing anything
that would give them a reason
to do a catastrophic action
like nuclear weapons,
unconventional weapons.
We've been very cautious
and deliberate every step of the way.
But another really important
point is
we should never allow dictators
and rogue nations
to dictate the terms
of what
we're willing to do
to defend our partners
every time
Putin or Lavrov has established
some kind of red line.
We have
done things to support Ukraine,
and they haven't
escalated from that point.
So we should not give Vladimir Putin
or anybody else, for that matter,
a veto authority over
what we're willing to do
to stand by our friends.
These attack them.
So these are the longer range missiles
that would dramatically increase
Ukraine's capability.
We're talking about
going to almost 200 miles distance.
Right.
There was concern before the White House
softened on this a little bit about
this could take the U.S.
into World War Three.
You would be giving the capability
to the Ukrainians of going
well into Russia.
How do you get assurances?
How do you ensure
that they don't do that?
I just don't buy that
because we have seen now 16
months into that this war
of Zelensky
and the
Ukrainians have shown their capability
to actually be a good partner.
They are not going to
jeopardize aid from the United States
by misusing our aid.
We have asked for assurances
that they're not going to use our weapons
and our technology to strike into Russia.
They have kept those assurances.
They have kept those promises,
and there's absolutely no reason
to believe
that they're going to break that promise
because it's
not in their interest to do so.
So they're going to do
what they need to do to win.
They'll use their own technology
to do cross-border
strikes, their own weapons and equipment
but they're not going to use U.S.
aid to do that.
And I don't think we have any reason
to believe that they would.
All right. We'll follow this.
We'll see what the reaction is from
the White House
to this request
that this bipartisan group,
including yourself, were making
Congressman Jason Crow.
Thanks for your time. Good to be on.